vamos a ver si podemos escribir la
fracción 11 25 a vos o sea 11 entre 25
como un número decimal y vamos a
redondear los decimales hasta el lugar
de las milésimas entonces saber para
escribir esto como un número decimal
lo que hacemos es tal cual / 11 / 25 ok
entonces tenemos que poner 11 entre 25 y
bueno el 25 definitivamente no cabe
adentro del 11 entonces seguro vamos a
necesitar poner números decimales
entonces ya de una vez pongamos el
número decimal aquí le ponemos 0 y como
queremos redondear al lugar de las
milésimas pues si una vez hay que poner
cuatro ceros a la derecha del punto
entonces cuántas veces cabe 25 en 110
pues 100 entre 4 son 25 entonces yo digo
que intentemos con el 44 por 5 son 20 y
aquí vamos 2
4 por 2 182 son 10 en efecto 4 por 25 si
son 100 y a la hora de restarle 110
menos 100 lo que nos queda son 10 y
entonces bajamos el otro 0
y bueno ya sabemos que 25 por 4 son 100
entonces aquí queda perfectamente 14 25
por 4 son 100
que restamos y entonces lo que nos queda
de residuo es 0 así es que ya terminamos
y ni siquiera fue necesario redondear lo
al lugar de las milésimas 1125 abós es
igual a 0.44